all right tony
tony borges tony borges yes tony uh you
you have a very interesting project that
you're doing
a housing project yes involving housing
for um for schools
commercial and for residential
and 10 years ago i came up with this
system
to build for the homeless and
laid it all out 10 years ago had
marketed a little bit when we were doing
the schools
and it just it never came across
and then i rethought what i was doing
and i came up with a i thought a better
solution for what we're doing
and the solution is to hire uh
five to ten percent of the homeless to
build the structures
and we've been building these structures
since 1980
we've done it where we've went to
islands
and took non-skilled labor to build them
when so we've been doing it forever
but what i did from the ones that we did
nine years ago
they were smaller houses now i came out
with a houses
that would be for the women and kids
one for the women and women the other
would be for
men and men we can make them two-story
they can go on a from a one acre to a
five to ten acre site of land
they can be also the men could be
two-story
if we get a tight site we're right now
we're putting the
funds together to start from san pedro
to lancaster to build 12 facilities
so these are homeless communities that
we have in this community
now to give you an idea of the homeless
community
if you're familiar with like a mobile
home park
you're like a mobile home park a mini
mobile home park
except they're really building the same
buildings we build the schools the same
quality
so you have a building process yeah
that's very unique yeah
yeah we've been doing it since 1980. and
tell me about that the process of
building
well we've been building schools there's
a
company called dsa or our state
architects
called dsa all this product is built
under dsa
requirements like so it's all
all ada all handicapped could be
anything that we want to build
out of this product so that's what we're
doing and they're
the structures are built fairly quickly
right yeah well they're made in
a factory then they've taken out to the
job site that's where we train the
people to actually put them back
together
and then also uh erect them
and finish them on the job site how many
how long does it take to build
and once the the building gets on the
job site five days
five days to build a an average square
foot house
they're 540 feet up to 600 feet
so small small structures but well yeah
but i mean they're very high quality
they're nine foot high ceilings
we didn't cut any corners but these
homes are also
fire resistant there's no wood in them
but they're just the same buildings that
we've built schools out of
and you would select uh
workers from the homeless community you
would train them yeah train them
yeah at one time we had the factory
about 25 30 years ago
in uh in torrance
and i moved the factory to compton
and i couldn't find any workers so i'd
get the workers
because no one wants to go to compton
yeah yeah there was there were black
people there and i go what's
okay i've been all over africa i was in
africa
in 1959 60
with the u.s government building water
projects
and sewer systems for africa so i've
been around working with people but when
i moved to compton
my workers wouldn't go to compton so i
would get them from the
jail they would bust them in from the
jail and we were
one time building four houses an hour in
the factory
this was a little 52 meter house 544
feet
and we'd take non-skilled labor and
build them in the factory
okay that went when reagan was
in they were going for the
the contra missile people one day where
those homes were
developed for so do you have any support
from
local governments or anything like that
no we're we
i bypass the local government right now
because the two or three times that i
have talked to them
or the couple they got their money
all set aside like the schools
and that's why the buildings are costing
400 to 600 000 a unit
and these buildings that we're building
in the factory cost
only about eighty five thousand time you
put them on the land
and do the site work you're probably a
hundred and fifty thousand
so it it's about half the price half the
quality
and these are also they're solar solar
powered
uh other solar yeah they're solar so
everything we've been doing
is what we're doing for here
so that's the same quality we're also
working on
building fire resistant homes and uh
and the fire resistant homes that we're
gonna build
uh gonna go out in paradise and as you
know fire but it's a
home that has no wood we have a
product that we developed that is ul
approved gives you a three hour firewall
now like up in paradise where they had
the big fires
we also make buildings that would be
where people can go in there
and lock yourself in for 72 hours
and let the fire burn by and go from
there
so the home is actually a protection
yeah
when we start doing this we're going to
open up
three major factories in la county
okay one factory will be to to build the
kits we call them kits
the next one will be building the
equipment to build
the panels and then the next one will be
the thermal shield
which actually is a product that we
developed
that you put on a building and it gives
you a three-hour firewall so that
product but it also not only gives you a
three-hour firewall
the other thing it does it actually
drops the temperature 35-40 degrees
if a house is in the cold area it keeps
it warm if it's in a hot area it keeps
it cool
but it's a product that we used on the
school it's dsa approved
and it's ul approved okay it's a product
that we develop
so that's what we're up to but then this
building business
i've been doing this this product since
1980
we had some good runs with big companies
like morrison knutson
and companies like that that we did in
the philippines and
different other countries that we did
things for
but we've been doing this forever our
background was concrete
we know more about concrete than anybody
i started building
everything from orville dam to missile
silos in
in santa maria
up there humpback so we've been
in the concrete business we did bart in
the bay area we did a lot of work at the
l.a airport
and all the parking structures and we
did
dams we did three dams
they were supposed to build 23 dams in
the state we did three of them
and then they ran out of money but we
came down with the feather river project
from
orville all the way to san diego doing
different parts of the project so our
background was concrete when i was in
africa
i tried to build concrete homes thought
well
i'm in the concrete business i should be
able to build concrete home
it sound it seems like it works you end
up with a box
but the cost and the labor and the
amount of equipment you need
makes it not feasible okay so
what we're doing now the three plants
that we're setting up here
in la they will take this and then we're
going to take it to
four sites in la or la county
and the site will have a school have the
thing to train the people
uh how to put them back together
and then also the job site we're gonna
need
anywhere from two to four thousand
people
to uh to start this project well having
employment for a lot of these people
would change their lives yeah yeah and
they would
have the ongoing employment for they're
gonna pay oh yeah they'll be
because when we get them trained we'll
be doing work
in paradise and what we're going to do
is put what we call them a satellite
plant
so we're going to take the same thing
put it up there
and the people that were training here
would go
there and and work
up there in that job the company that's
putting in the money
wants us to have 10 000 people to work
so and um as you know i'm getting
calls from san jose
san francisco we're talking to some
people in washington
uh we know we got a deal in texas
and in florida so that this would
potentially be a new location for the
homeless communities in these cities
yeah yeah these are and and what go back
and look at the homeless
and what is people don't they don't want
anybody in their backyard
but if you put them in a gated community
a secured gating community and
select the ones you're going to put in
there under qualification
okay we know that some of them that need
medical help and different things
but this is actually a home what we have
to do is find a way to bring some
dignity
back into the homeless market because
right now
all they're doing is just taking the
money putting it in our pocket
the big boys and they're not doing
what they should be doing and one they
need jobs
okay number two they need a quality
place to live
and they need education to be there
no i think i think just being employed
yeah builds self-esteem and
yeah as the employment we're gonna pay
15
an hour to as they're in school for
eight weeks
we're gonna pay them fifteen dollars an
hour when they come out of school it's
gonna go from twenty to twenty seven
dollars an hour
okay this whole project and we got it
all
on paper it's all pencils out we know
exactly what how much money we need to
spend and how much we got to put in
are you looking for help from anybody or
yeah we're going to be looking for
non-profit organizations to manage these
and that's where ida comes in she's
going to be
setting up the people's the non-profits
is your marketing director
as a marketing director yes
and so that's what we're doing she's
marketing director for that and also
for the the fire resistant homes
okay chs has been in business since 1959
building roads freeways water projects
dams
we had the patents on the center divider
for the freeways and the big pavers
i had something to do with every freeway
out here in california
in 1960 there was nothing out here at
all
so we did concrete was our background
back in those days
and so um but the reason i got into this
housing the way we're doing it
is that every time i would go to these
other countries
like brazil and argentina and that the
first thing they would ask you
do you have houses we're also working on
farming communities for other countries
i got one farming community we're
working on now
that they're supposed to be funding and
that's in laos
and that's a seven square mile farming
community to start
so that package is all together and
building housing there
huh you're building housing there it
will be houses buildings
they want to raise 5 000 cattle a year
for the market but it's everything from
dairies
to farming to roads it's just raw land
right now and we laid it all out
but that's what we're doing on that also
we have a gentleman
as one of our funding sources wants to
do it in africa
because they're talking about africa
having not enough food to feed their
people
so we're trying to take things that need
to be
done and do it now that package is
completely done
and we know the cost we know what we're
doing and how
the one in laos it started all the way
from
road to you name it all it is is just
we're all land
and going from there in laos so that's
where we are
that sounds great so uh we got other
countries
uh that we're talking to
to do that so once you get this
the funding you need you'd be off and
running yeah it's all
you need some land though too right oh
yeah no they they
these people want they want
jobs it's all about jobs so it's all
about
uh training people yeah we need i would
think there's some motivation from the
cities to
fix their homeless problem and yeah find
the land somewhere and yeah
well here finding land the city in the
county has a lot of land
they got it in their pocket for somebody
else
we got to get to the point where we can
be
up front once we see what we're doing
and that's what we're up to where we can
actually employ people
here in town okay
the money people are asking us can we go
to take this thing down
to uh new york can we go to florida
with the unemployment the homelessness
so this is a solution okay
is there other solutions out there it
probably is
but after thinking about this whole
thing and you see the designs of the
buildings and you see the quality of the
building
these buildings are guaranteed to last
150 years
yeah and plus you're you're putting the
guys to work too yeah
it's all about jobs it's all about
taking non-skilled labor and training
them
and the big problem they have with jobs
today for the homeless
they work a week or two and then they
they're gone they work a week or two and
they're gone
here it's going to be a long term so
that's what we're up to so you see why
we have a marketing director
we have about 14 people engineers and
everybody working with the company
people that run the plants and that but
i did shut the
plant down here uh because the contracts
for the schools
just ran out why actually they ran out
of money they still need the buildings
but they ran out of money
so that's where we are we're going to be
looking for people to
join with us and fun
this time we have a non-profit
organization we're setting up
and we have a tax id number that we can
actually put this whole thing together
okay excellent well tony thank you so
much for telling us about your
project that's where we're at that
sounds great okay
you know you basically have a nice
solution to the homeless problem yeah
yeah and it's not only a solution if we
can provide
jobs of high quality or a decent quality
and long-term jobs okay and train the
people in schools
it's all about education it's all about
training people
and putting and then when the people go
to work for it
they have a way that they can move up
they don't they're just not locked into
something doing something the rest of
their life they can actually move
up with talent excellent okay all right
tony well thank you so much so that's
where we're at
awesome but thank you that's great bye